Let me show you what Max pulling what pulling does and then why
you would use pooling. So here you can see when we have this.
If this is a picture the super pixel or the sub sample if the
whole Matrix the sample then a sub sample is a section.
You will take the strongest or the maximum
value in this in this particular section. It's
the number three in this section. It's
the number four.
In this section is the number two.
And here it's 4 that's what Max pooling does.
Now Max pooling is done for two purposes.
the max pooling Matrix
is used to achieve.
following one
reduce
the computational load of
computing
activations
You know like in the brain's neuron, right? Yeah, or
the perceptor we talked about the signal
the travels down the neuron we want to make it less come
or something because this picture is a
32 by 32 pictures.
32.3 is a tiny picture.
When in reality?
The kinds of picture you would see on the internet are 300 by
300 500 by 5. If you're
using a DS if using a dslrs or a mirrorless camera like
they want to have in here.
It will be Million by million.
Like 13 million by 30 million.
so
and imagine you want to do this in real time. It will be very
demanding
and that's just for one picture. Imagine. We have like a folder of
pictures. So this Max pooling will really make it
easier to
figure out what's in the what's the picture?
The second part of Max pooling is to handle.
Or not let them use another word.
To it is called translational invariants.
The word I want to use is what?
to
become
translationally invariant
what this is what me, I'll
there's another slide slide over here based on
the Kernel size and the stride. Yes, exactly. So the
output will depend on the size of the kernel.
and destroyed
small stories are better, but they are more time consuming.
Does a maximal identify which kind of illusional curl
in the previously had the highest match?
Does Max pool identify which kind of
illusional?
Not the kernel.
The sub-sample in The convolutional Matrix and if
I bring it back to the book.
it is not the kernel from
which the filter from which we're getting the
max value from the origin convolution
so for example if I bring you back this
here
Do you see this? Do you see this grid this red this three
by three red grid
So in this picture or in this corner?
Let's say we what we actually want dark colors because
we want to find out the outlines. So we want to discard the
white background and focus only on
the
outline the face. So here the strong signals will be the docker
pixels.
So you can see here in this three by three.
The largest value is the one
at the bottom right corner.
And then for example if I come here.
The strongest signal will be in the top left.
top left
corner
I hope that answers your question.
Again, the way you would arrange the numbers in the filter will
depend on the color Channel.
And what you are trying to detect if I scroll
down here?
Let me show you what what habits this
picture when you apply different filters.
identity will obviously identity will give you
the same image, but for example if I put in
blur
you can see that it did
it work identity.
It's very subtle. Let me reduce the
numbers here
Miss playing around.
Darkness
It's very solid but it is blurred.
So, I mean the numbers would put in this in
this filter or kernel all depend
on what you're trying to do.
I guess there was another link here which we can look up.
Great.
Okay. Well, let me come back here. Let me come back to the
this point here. What do they mean by translationally invariant?
But we already saw translation back in module 2
when we were
When we took that plane and we applied shearing
to it, but there is this nice presentation from Harvard.
Which does a good job of explaining?
Or visualizing invariance. So
let me skip to that section.
Yeah, so these are the different types of filters you can use.
Again, we will use the word filter and kernel interchangeably. This is the identity. You
just put a one in here.
You get the same picture?
If you want add detection.
You can use these numbers.
Okay.
sharpen if you want to
pre-process the data
Let me show you translation.
This is an example.
Simply one of the picture is off center.
Here's another example.
We have different types of invariants, right?
Let's say in the c410 data
set.
The pictures are merely in the center, but they
can be a little bit off center. Maybe the pictures too
big or something. Excuse me. The subject is too big.
Or the subject is too small or here if it
may be rotated so here for example, the subject is
in the center, but it's rotated. The max pooling
is meant for this purpose. It's them it's to make the model resilient.
to translations
This is size and variance see exactly so
in some of the pictures and the c410 is
that the subject takes up the entire almost the inside
of the picture in some cases. It's small.
Illumination, right? So it's the same object, but you can see because the light
Is being emitted from different angles it can really
change.
the content of the picture
that's what Max is pulling is used for.